welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
aka the clown prince of youtube and this
video we've got a pretty big rumor to
talk about in regards to the batman
throughout it i'm just going to be
breaking down everything i've heard
about
rumors surrounding barry kyogen and
because of this
there's gonna be a lot of spoilers now
if you don't want anything ruined then
it's time to activate the nightfall
protocol
and shut down your entire computer burn
all evidence
you dirty dirty bad boy however if you
enjoyed this video then please throw a
batarang at that thumbs up button
and make sure you subscribe to the
channel for videos like this every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our breakdown
okay so if you cast your mind back to a
couple of months ago
you might remember that we dropped a
video discussing a message that we've
been sent about a joker cameo
that would be in the upcoming batman
film he would reportedly appear for a
brief moment in arkham asylum
which batman would visit during one of
the many scenes in the movie
now according to the message i was sent
the creative team behind the movie were
using a stand-in at this point
and they hadn't actually cast an actor
in the role i took this
with an and say it with me a grain of
salt at the time
but since then there's been a lot of
things i've heard behind the scenes that
seem to confirm that not only is this
the case
but that barry kyogen could in fact be
playing the character
i'm gonna completely butcher barry
kyogen's name this entire video
but as i'm sure you're all aware the
filming on the movie was shut down
recently due to a cast member catching
coronavirus
and just before it was about to resume i
got a message from the same person that
sent me the firefighter helmet
saying that filming was going to resume
on the 17th of september
this turned out to be true and with this
message they also said that there was a
member of the cast who was not playing
who everyone thought that they were
oh my god it's all a lie if i turn up
dead
you know exactly who did it and right
now warner brothers are probably gonna
hit me up like
from your secret friends
now i do trust this message as it comes
from the same person that leaked a lot
of behind the scenes info to me
and i started doing my own detective
work to try to find out who this person
actually was
initially i thought that gil coulson
might be the bait and switch
and that he would actually be harvey
dent aka two-face
this could still be the case but from
discussing things further
i've learned that barry kyogen might
actually be the person
who's not who we think he is now take
this with a grain of assault and battery
but since filming has restarted i've
spoken to a couple of people that have
said kyogen is actually playing a major
villain
and not stanley merkel which is who he's
been officially announced as
i understand that i'm getting all dude
bro trust me at the moment
and i really wish that i could reveal my
sources as it does suck kind of
kind of putting my neck on the line for
this but bear with me
i promise it'll be worth your time now
it does actually seem like some outlets
are even along the right lines with
everything and
after the casting of kyogen newspaper
the express
theorized that he was actually playing
the real riddler
they don't typically tend to cover this
kind of thing so
to me at least someone has heard
something very similar to what i have
and they're passing it off as a theory
article which
yeah people do that from time to time
because they can't get in trouble for it
now as for who kyogen is supposed to be
playing stanley merkel
is actually jim gordon's partner in the
comics in the graphic novel dark victory
the character was killed by the hangman
and that was pretty much the end of that
i don't know if kyogen would take this
role especially with the star being an
up-and-comer
so it does seem a bit weird to me that
he would be on board with something
that will probably get overshadowed by
gordon and be a tiny bit part
kyogen also only recently got cast and
as we've seen from the trailer
one of the big cop scenes has been shown
and he was nowhere to be seen
surely if he was actually his partner he
would have been at the scene to
investigate the crime
and the only plausible reason i can
think of that you wouldn't be there
as he's either brought in later in the
movie or he's not at all
normally during a film's production they
tend to have the cast ready from the
beginning
but the fact that kyogen is coming in so
late into the production
does hint at him doing a smaller role or
even a cameo
this would line up massively with the
apparent visit that batman has to arkham
asylum
and he could come face to face with him
there which would tease him reappearing
as the villain in later movies down the
line
i can see a lot of people thinking that
the eternals is also a comic book movie
so
it doesn't make sense to have it this
close however the next batman film
probably won't be out until
2023 at the earliest and thus i think
that there would be enough distance
between the properties
now batman on film has been hinting that
he's also been doing a different role to
what we know about
and shout outs big bat theory for
dropping one on how he might actually be
playing the mad hatter
i was speaking to them today about the
whole casting rumors so i thought i'd go
over
what they had to say about it so big bat
theory thinks that kyogen is playing
stanley merkel
who will also be mad hatter they stated
this situation is comparable to when
liam neeson was cast as decor
but was really roswell ghoul it's a it's
racial goo
i'll call him ross just to stay in line
with the movie now the studio didn't lie
about his role
as the character is identified as decard
in the film
but it worked to hide his purpose in the
plot big bat theory thinks that the
situation with merkel is gonna
be very very similar now the reasons
that barry kyogen's secret role could be
the mad hatter
is that hata was rumored to be in the
film since the very beginning
the casting of the carver twins points
to hat as involvement
kyogen is a perfect mad hatter in looks
and he's also
cool as hell a big bat theory said that
if they wanted to reinvent hatter
he'd be a drug dealer slash cult leader
inspired by charles manson
in this situation technological mind
control devices
would be replaced with manipulation and
abuse tactics
he'd also be a deadhead hippie because
no one else is that obsessed with alice
in wonderland
and we know that there was a significant
drug bust that happened before the
events of the film
we know that police corruption is also a
major part of the batman's plot
so big bad theory is kind of tying this
all together
now they think that stanley merkel might
actually be a corrupt cop
who has been tasked with moving
confiscated drugs he may even be an
undercover cop
whose alias is jarvis tech as a police
officer
no other dealers and gangsters would
mess with him and that power plus the
drug use could explain him going mad
this theory wouldn't be a very comic
book accurate mad hatter
but it would explain why batman would
interact with him in the plot
he'd be connected to the corruption and
possibly even the penguin
who appears to be doing some type of
drug deal when batman shows up
again really good theory in my opinion
and whilst none of this might be true
i think it's safe to say that there's a
lot of people who aren't drinking the
kool-aid when it comes to his casting
kyogen is an absolutely fantastic actor
and over the last couple of years
he's been in dunkirk chernobyl and will
of course be in the upcoming eternals
film
he's clearly someone you get when you
want to do something big and to seem
relegated to be
just a policeman doesn't really make
that much sense to me
to come in the cast this late in the
game coupled with the things i've heard
from people on set saying that one actor
is a fake out
it all kind of lines up to make me think
that we're getting something far
different to what we'd expect
warner bros obviously want to keep some
surprises for us too so
bringing in the actor but keeping his
true role a surprise
would hint at him being a larger part of
the trilogy and yeah
something just seems very suspicious
here maybe i'm wrong though and
the joke's on me or maybe the jokes on
you
are you watching this if you don't think
that he's actually the joker
mad hats off to us though if we get this
right
like mad hat sub this video now
let us know your thoughts on these
rumors below and which one you agree
with
if any if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown on the snyder cuts new scene
announcements which is going to be
linked at the end
we go over the project's newly announced
budget what it's being used for and also
the ray fisher drama
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more also giving away a
free copy of the christopher nolan
collection
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of september so make
sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chatters on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best i've been
paul and i'll see you next time
take care peace
you